hello you're playing the waiting game
the video game recommendation show this
week if you really reap what you sow
we're gonna need a new gardener yes
diablo 3 reaper of souls their first bit
of dlc for blizzards dungeon crawler is
rapidly approaching its launching in
march to be precise the plot centers
around the black soulstone which mal
fell through Malthe IL the Angel of
Death plans to steal using it for all
kinds of evil it's down to you to stop
this moderately nefarious plan from
coming to fruition so what's the best
way to get ready I'll tell you well if
you're looking for a tale of one person
taking on the forces of evil you can't
get much better than Dante's Inferno
that's the third person slaughter game
by the way not Dante's epic poem though
that is in itself pretty great in the
game version Dante is lesser wandering
poet and more of a brutal warrior sent
to rescue his love by murdering
everything with a strong focus on hack
and slash mechanics it's not as much of
a methodical dungeon crawl out as Diablo
3 but it's a pretty underrated game one
you can romp through pretty quickly just
in time for Reaper of souls of course
lone heroes have been taking on nearly
insurmountable evils for thousands of
years now and if you really want to get
ready for Reaper of souls you should
check out one of the first Beowulf is a
wonderful poem written sometime between
the eighth and eleventh centuries it's
also a film starring Ray Winstone but if
you dare watch that I will pull my head
off and Bowl it at you seriously it's
atrocious I am Ripper Tara slasher
Gouger I am the team to the darkness the
challenge in the night my knees spread
and
a power by Bauer anyway Beowulf tells
the story of the gates a group of
Scandinavian warriors being terrorized
by the monstrous Grendel the eponymous
warrior Beowulf arrives to lend his aid
and the action goes from there I went
for the rest but rest assured it's a
tremendous work of fiction I wrote my
dissertation on it actually anyway
unless you can understand the original
anglo-saxon you'll need to read it in
translation the Seamus Heaney rendering
is probably the most popular though
personally I prefer the translation done
by Kevin crossly Holland I'll look at me
anti pretentious now while Beowulf is
fantastic i recognize anglo-saxon poetry
might not exactly be for everyone maybe
you want something a bit more
lighthearted to get ready for the diablo
dlc don't worry we've got you covered
and onto this all now destined to wear
the jeweled crown of Aquilonia upon a
troubled brow going on the Barbarian
tells the story of a barbarian named
Conan he's looking to exact his revenge
on the evil wizard who killed his family
years before Conan is a bloody romp the
likes of which only the 1980s could
possibly produce featuring some hugely
over-the-top set pieces and some
incredibly quotable dialogue Han what is
best in life to crush your enemies see
them driven before you know you're a
lamentation of the women to be honest if
you go into diablo 3 reaper of souls
without at least one army movie behind
you then you really have my pity
speaking of Conan the Barbarian our next
recommendation was very heavily
influenced by arne sweaty escapades
leading to a game that's just about as
iconic i am talking of course about gold
max
says in the land of urea Golden Axe
follows three warriors on a quest to
kill the evil death adder and free their
King from captivity the side-scrolling
Sega Genesis game became an instant
classic when it was released over 20
years ago and if you want a challenging
hack and slash game to warm you up for
Reaper of souls you'd be hard-pressed to
do better just don't let the rather
questionable box up at you off and
finally in this demonic debacle we've
got one more game to get you ready for
diablo 3 reaper of souls and that's
diablo 2 no really yeah I know we try
not to mention previous games in the
series too often but there's a very good
reason for it this time round doubtless
you're aware that diablo 3 had a rather
mixed reception when it initially
launched a lot of people seem to think
the gameplay had wandered off course
somewhat and didn't clutch the new
release to their hearts as dearly as
they did diablo 2 the whole point of the
Reaper of souls DLC then is to react the
style of gameplay everyone loved in
diablo 2 bringing the franchise back to
the form that won people over in the
first place the new zone is much darker
the loot drops have been reconfigured
and the Crusader is also quite like the
Paladin everyone loved in diablo 2 so to
get yourself ready for those challenges
re familiarizing yourself with the
previous iteration is a pretty sound
tactic and with that i'm off as ever if
you want to have a closer look at any of
the items we talked up in this episode
follow the link on screen now for an
amazon list the waiting game will return
next week but sadly I won't this is my
last episode in charge of the waiting
game as I'm going on to new things but
rest assured you'll be in good hands
when said takes over in the next episode
don't forget to make your own
recommendations in a comment or by
tweeting with a hashtag GS waiting game
it's been a pleasure yeah well
you